cette opération précipitée se place
directement dans la perspective proche
des élections législatives le
gouvernement Messmer est un gouvernement
de campagne électorale nous allons sans
doute assister à un nouvel assaut de
démagogie sociale sous la houlette
d'Edgar fort orfèvre en la matière mais
visiblement la mise en place d'une
équipe restreinte placée directement
sous les ordres de l'Élysée
annonce surtout un renforcement du
caractère personnel autoritaire
anti-démocratique du pouvoir
le programme commun de gouvernement sera
au centre de l'importante bataille
politique que vont constituer les
élections législatives dans un
communiqué commun publié jeudi dernier
les soci
alistes et les radicaux qui s'opposent à
Servan-Schreber déclare qu'il publieront
dès la semaine prochaine les premières
listes des candidats qu'il présenteront
au premier tour des élections
législatives ils ajoutent qu'au deuxième
tour de scrutin les candidats
appliqueront la discipline de l'union de
la gauche cette discipline je le
rappelle suppose que les candidats de
gauche se désistent au second tour pour
celui d'entre eux que le suffrage
universel a placé en tête à l'issue du
premier tour